I swore that we would be together forever
I was happy when
I met him I thought I liked him more I
was happy
Thank you
for making me happy  Oh,
so much happiness is so great
I had to share it with that person
[music]
That's why, hey, hey
, what am I right now
?
nn
[music] nn ran nn [music] 2 Nothing to do with allergies [music]
That's
ah ah ah
ha
j I
'm sorry
, there are no injuries.  That's right,
I came out after moving, and I know it's there, but my master won't come out
.
It's okay
I can't help but wonder if you came from somewhere else
.
People like us who don't have any ties are
not suitable for sightseeing.
I don't think I'm in a position to say anything, but Aid Is there a place you
want to go?
[Music]
me
jr  ]
[Music]
This is what
I wanted to see.  I wonder if my
dream came true and I made some good memories I wonder if there's anything left to
remember
Thank you so much for today There were so many wonderful things
It's all thanks
to you  Heh,
it was like a dream, but I'm running out of time.
Lastly, I have one request. Please
forget about me.  I wonder if I'll be happy if you give it to me
What is that?
Leaving Americans
I've seen that geoglyph I'm ready to die when I decide to look for it I heard you were looking for it
Today I brought you a job A military related mountain
Yes
It
doesn't matter if it's blatantly painful This guy doesn't need a special technical background The condition is that he's a trustworthy
guy  It seems like it's better to be a
shop
that satisfies the conditions so far.
I guess you want to live I guess
you can't forgive yourself for being happy now
I can't help but give
up, but you're still living,
right
?  I don't know what to do, but I do
n't have to worry about fighting or killing.
It seems like it's crazy, but I'll tell you the story, so please ask me for details on site
.
[Music]
This is tan
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah  Where is everyone?
9 frames List you 3
Well, somehow
, I should be able to live.
is here  Before that, here's my color madder
I put up a net, but click We're still good friends, aren't we? But that friendship is over.
We're operating jointly,
so even if it's just a matter of theory, we need administrators from both
sides I got an introduction and you're the administrator for
the military
It just brings out the flavor of the dish
so much.It looks delicious because it's only increased by receiving and processing the current material.In other
words, the risk of life is increased by 20%.
But even if it's a rare feast in the world,
I'm not going to
give a verdict at the moment.
Of course, I was thinking if the person himself said he can
eat it.
What am I supposed to do?  I didn't show my face,
so what are you going to do now?
What do you think of these
people-eating
demons?
I
'm so happy, don't get me wrong This isn't a young man or woman or anything like that
This guy is just trying to fatten up a whole sheep that seems genuinely delicious
It's
really a lot
, I just want you to let me do it.
That's right, it's this building, isn't it?
Riyo It
doesn't look like it's running at all, but it doesn't look like it's a gun or a cannon
Let's talk about
that tomorrow  You
have to go back
to your roomEeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeer before that
It's a lively place
Well, Mr. Water, how long have you been sleeping
?  Half
[music] It
's
not generated.
The first thing I'll answer is your question My
favorite food is spicy meat dishes I'm not good at
reptorace food No relationship with Blur is a farmer and a stray Tsukoko
Until this morning, numbers 28 and 23
[music]
It's a beautiful name,
Willem
Ghoul.
What are you guys doing
?
I
'm sorry about those
kids.
I'm sorry about my wife
just now.
yo my name
box
It's really late, but I
really didn't introduce myself, so ah
Bill wasted,
nice to meet you 9
Good
night, just one thing I want to ask
you  You can't see it in the warehouse,
or you can't find the essential weapons anywhere.
I did
n't know you came, but I was dating those girls
Ah,
maybe you're
the one who moves with just the momentum of the place
[music]
Well, I'll tell you now
The answer is the first question
What does it
mean? It
's not difficult as you said.
[Applause]
tan
[Music]
ni
plus nao
[Music]
goo
me
[Music]
[Applause]
ah ah ah
[Music]
Even so, I wonder if I can't say something witty at times like
this.
That's what you say,
right? That's more dramatic, so I'll kill you first
I understand that
kind of reasoning.
Well, that's
why if your father is about to go to the final battle,
hold on to something certain.
I don't have the confidence to send my father off smiling tomorrow
Butter cake mold
Yeah, I really like that about you I'll
ask for an oversized one for my next birthday
too  I
'll compromise with that.In exchange, I'll have you eat cake until you get heartburn.In
less than a year from the 6th night, mankind perished, of
course, idiot.  Jijun Hero Couldn't Keep His Promise Next Time In
the Forest Above the Sky
[Music]